you realize that at 39 if you accomplish
whatever your goals and dreams are that
that's just as good as accomplishing it
at 25. probably better and more likely
and more sustainable then you can start
reframing the way you look at [__]
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
Ryan Smith is the owner of the Utah Jazz
excited to have him on because we're
recording this a mere 10 or so days
before All-Star Weekend in Utah so we
are just hours away now from NBA
All-Star weekend and downtown Salt Lake
is bustling for all the events including
one that is about an interactive
experience for you they didn't feel like
the man of the year you know like what's
fun about business I knew that I could
keep it low-key so that I could get like
real time with people gratitude is my
latitude if something
Tony took a pregnancy test and found out
oh my God gratitude is like everything
for us right now I think about it all
the time meanwhile back to gratitude the
millions of people right down that just
can't get pregnant are destined to not
have a child when they want that more
than anything on Earth they kind of like
reframes your brain in a second totally
the [__] that people take for granted
I'm in school right now just have been
struggling I guess trying to find like
what you like what I like for a purpose
are you doing school for yourself are
you doing it for your parents it's
probably a mix of both would they be
devastated if you bounced my dad
probably would I think you have to have
that compo with him it's a good combo
for you to have with them the answer is
you don't want to do it yeah you
wouldn't have brought it up to me if you
did yeah are you collecting debt not
right now but starting next year you
can't do that yeah that's one of like
the bigger reasons why I'm like even now
like kind of wanted to
you got to say Dad I love you this isn't
for me and I can't take on personal debt
or something that's not me I've been
doing it for you because I love you but
I can't take on the step he may say I'll
pay for it then you have a different
decision to make but you can't make a
decision of doing something you don't
want to do to collect on that you can't
do that you've been a big inspiration
break we have a small podcast here in
Utah and one of the reasons why we still
keep doing it you never know whose life
you can change
I'm aware that part bothers me a little
bit I'm jealous of that
no not until we earn it ourselves I just
want to say I'm a sellout I [__] hate
the Bulls so much I'm so pissed right
now you have no idea
foreign
I love work too I do nails and I just
opened up a silver shop and I don't know
how to balance my time between them my
beautiful family and doing what I love
love in itself is a balancer even just
being around the four of you right now I
have a very good feeling that they're
not confused that you're not about them
they know that you love them there's a
lot of people that are home at five
o'clock every night
there are plenty and the kids and the
husband and the wife like don't feel the
love balance is individual balance is
very circumstantial what I think about
is balance of heart and intent and love
I have a funny feeling that if one of
these three needed you that the silver
shop and the nail shop you'd burn to the
[__] ground yes it was well that's
the [__] answer to your question and
by the way you're also inspiring them
you're showing your daughter what it's
like to be a [__] boss female to
execute you're showing her that example
balance is based on the intent not the
[__] logging the hours I get a
thousand percent
foreign
[Music]
see you soon okay see you soon I'll be
ready for you my guy
let's first hear it for the host of this
entire weekend Ryan Smith
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I I think that you have to ask the
simple question of why are you doing it
most of the social that's out there
isn't working because it's selfish you
want the likes you want the money you
want to sell the thing and we don't want
that you need to put out things that
provide value and they can come in a lot
of shapes and sizes I'll tell you who
I'm really fascinated by the people who
are posting on a daily basis who have
very tiny tiny audiences and enjoy it to
no end they enjoy it because they just
want to share videos of them playing
video games or cooking or things of that
nature this becomes a very simple game
of why are you doing this you do it
because you love the thing that you're
putting out there and it's part of the
process you're gonna win the problem is
too many people want certain things and
they want it fast so do you know that
they're yelling at us because we're
being rude because somebody else has to
say so can you say goodbye thank you
well then that's what I'm trying to tell
you we're done we're finished right
thank you guys
thank you love you back yes what is one
tip you would give if I wanted to like
you know become known and like famous
well why do you want to become famous
it looks cool but is it
no probably not
what you really want to do is when you
make your videos make sure you're making
them for yourself and it's something you
actually believe in not a video that
you're doing because you think it will
do good too many people make videos that
they think will get views
but it's not really in their soul so if
you decide to get into that world when
you make videos make sure it's something
you actually want to make
you got it yeah my man thank you just
want to thank Utah in general for the
extraordinary love it's kind of nice to
be back in the mix with people you know
we're still a little rusty like getting
back into the grind of uh of vlogging I
want to do a little bit more of that and
Julian Dustin really appreciate you guys
a lot of deep insights felt like the
depth of the conversations today was
very real and when I'm not doing it
every day you get fresh perspectives one
thing I've been thinking a lot about
lately is just like I think some people
just think they're alone and they're
just not you know if you're watching
this and you think you're alone it
you're not alone you just haven't found
those people I really really want to
focus on that more
[Music]
foreign